>>Alison: I can discuss whether or not
confederate monuments should be removed
by listening to my peers,
and using evidence.
>>Linda: By talking and expressing
oneself, we learn more deeply.
>>One thing we know from
the science of learning is
that complex instruction needs to
be scaffolded, that students need
to be enabled to take each step
along the path and in this classroom,
we see a very sophisticated conversation
being scaffolded to help them learn how
to talk to each other about
this very difficult concept
in a very respectful and thoughtful way.
>>Alison: We've just finished a
six week unit on the Civil War.
They needed a safe space to talk about
racial issues and justice issues.
I decided a discussion would be the best
way for them to learn about the issue,
bring in evidence, and
have their voices be heard.
>>I sourced about fifteen
different articles to meet kids
where they were at, in
terms of length of texts
or level of complexity of texts.
>>Linda: Part of the
scaffolding in this classroom is
that this teacher has found fifteen
different texts for students to read,
to prepare for the discussion, so
that they can speak with evidence,
and so that their evidence
is accessible to them.
>>Alison: What's important
to understand,
that even though somebody says
something you might disagree with,
everybody's contributing
to this shared dialog
in this safe space. Somebody
start us off.
>>Student: I think confederate
monuments should be removed,
based on the Atlantic.
It said, "Establishing monuments
to confederate war heroes
in turn celebrates men
who committed treason."
>>Alison: I was very pleased
with a lot of students
who really came out of their shell.
>>Student: I want to disagree with a
lot of you, saying that they're bad.
>>Alison: I loved that
there was healthy debate.
>>Student: I don't know
about the rest of you,
but I don't them in this country.
>>Student: We need to find a
way for each side to be able
to see the opposing side's
points, instead of just argue them.
>>Alison: They were polite,
they were encouraging,
and I think it helps them understand
that deeper understanding of history.
>>Student: It's all in perspective.
If you know it's wrong, then
you can use it to create change.
>>Alison: So we're actually
going to stop there.
There were a couple people in the room
tracking things from the conversation.
>>Linda: She's thought about the fact
that some students may be
more comfortable participating
by tracking the conversation, and
then reporting out what they've found.
>>Student: Athen used evidence in
a cool way. He brought up how--
>>Linda: So there are many ways for
students to get their brains engaged
and to be participating
in this discussion.
The deep conversation they've just
had is actually extended by the fact
that they get to reflect
at the end, in writing.
>>Alison: Tell me how your thinking is
now changed after this conversation.
It's okay if it didn't change,
but you need to tell me why.
>>Linda: That reflection,
which is metacognitive,
really helps the students
carry more learning
out of the experience they've just had.